Ja, das ist das Video,
das ihr gesucht habt.
Hier beantworten wir sieben kritische
Fragen zu den Corona-Impfungen.
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich. Los geht's!
Und kann es so schnell
noch sicher sein?
Es gibt sechs Gründe,
warum's so schnell ging.
Globale Pandemie,
globaler Fokus in der Forschung.
Das erhöht
die Wahrscheinlichkeit auf Erfolg.
Und zwar wirklich viel Geld.
Beides ja auch Coronaviren. So musste
man hier nicht bei null anfangen.
Eine Impfstoffentwicklung folgt
einem streng kontrollierten Prozess,
um pharmazeutische Qualität,
Wirksamkeit und Sicherheit
zu gewährleisten.
Das war hier nicht anders.
Nur dieses Mal konnten Prozesse
parallel ablaufen
und sich teilweise überlappen,
durch Priorisierung
und genügend Ressourcen.
So ging's schneller,
aber es war nicht weniger sorgfältig.
Anstatt zu warten,
bis ein wissenschaftlicher Bericht
vollständig vorliegt,
prüfen die Behörden
derzeit kontinuierlich.
Also sie prüfen Datensätze sofort,
sobald sie da sind.
Jap, das ist an sich
natürlich schlecht,
aber für eine klinische Impfstudie
tatsächlich gut.
Denn die funktioniert so:
Die Testgruppe kriegt den Impfstoff,
die Kontrollgruppe
eine Placebo-Spritze.
Und dann schaut man
die nächsten Monate einfach,
was so passiert.
Hier sind die Daten
vom BioNTech/Pfizer-Impfstoff.
Die COVID-19-Fälle
in der Kontrollgruppe
steigen immer weiter, während die
Geimpften, nach kurzer Anlaufzeit,
kaum mehr krank werden.
Je stärker eine Pandemie wütet,
also je schneller
sich Leute anstecken,
desto schneller
sieht man einen Unterschied.
Deswegen konnten klinische Studien
innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit
mit eindeutigem Ergebnis
abgeschlossen werden.
Fazit: Die Impfstoffentwicklung
war so schnell,
weil sie priorisiert wurde
und Ressourcen reingepumpt wurden,
plus eine wütende Pandemie.
Die Gewährleistung
der pharmazeutischen Qualität,
der Wirksamkeit und der Sicherheit
wurde genauso sorgfältig gehandhabt
wie bei anderen
Impfstoffentwicklungen.
Jetzt wurde ein dritter Impfstoff
zugelassen, von AstraZeneca,
ein sogenannter Vektorimpfstoff,
mit einer Impfeffektivität
von 70 Prozent.
Das heißt, in den klinischen Studien
erkrankten 18 von 1.000
Nicht-Geimpfte an COVID-19.
Also, es wurden hier
nicht nur 1.000 Leute getestet,
sondern insgesamt rund 24.000.
Man schaut hier pro 1.000 Probanden,
um besser zu vergleichen.
Also, 18 von 1.000
Nicht-Geimpften wurden krank.
Bei den geimpften
waren es fünf von 1.000.
Das heißt 13 Menschen weniger,
also 70 Prozent weniger.
Daher kommen also
die 70 Prozent Effektivität.
Die STIKO,
die Ständige Impfkommission,
empfiehlt derzeit
den AstraZeneca-Impfstoff
für Erwachsene bis 64 Jahre.
Für Ältere haben die bisherigen Daten
noch nicht genug statistische Power,
um die Wirksamkeit
sicher zu beurteilen.
Es kann aber gut sein, dass die
Empfehlung demnächst erweitert wird,
sobald die Daten da sind.
Bis dahin kann es sein,
dass manche Jüngere
gegebenenfalls aus Prio
zwei oder drei vorrücken könnten.
Also früher drankommen könnten,
was diejenigen ja freuen dürfte.
Außerdem muss der Vektorimpfstoff
nicht so stark gekühlt werden
wie die mRNA-Impfstoffe,
was ein logistischer Vorteil ist.
So könnten irgendwann auch
die Hausärzte impfen. Auch super.
Jetzt denken sich
manche aber vielleicht:
"Ich will keinen Impfstoff
zweiter Klasse."
Ist ja klar.
Wenn ich die Wahl hätte
zwischen einem Impfstoff
mit 95 Prozent Effektivität
und einem mit 70 Prozent,
würde ich natürlich auch
den effektiveren nehmen.
Aber dieses Szenario
wird's erst mal nicht geben.
Wir haben natürlich viel weniger
Impfdosen als wir brauchen.
Es wird auch eine Zeit
lang noch so bleiben.
Das heißt, man wird
auf absehbare Zeit
wahrscheinlich nicht
frei wählen lassen,
sondern die Impfdosen
sinnvoll aufteilen.
Anders gesagt: Ich muss das nehmen,
was ich kriegen kann.
Und das ist auch völlig okay.
Denn sagen wir, das Krankheitsrisiko
meiner Oma wäre hier.
Dann ist ja mein Risiko
schon mal niedriger.
Und wenn jetzt meine Oma
durch die Impfung
das Risiko um 95 Prozent
reduzieren kann
und ich um 70 Prozent von hier aus,
dann ist mein Risiko am Ende
auch nicht viel höher als ihres.
Also das nimmt sich
in der Praxis gar nicht mehr so viel.
Diese 25 Prozent Unterschied
scheinen größer als sie sind.
70 Prozent Effektivität
sind wirklich solide.
Also, wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass die mRNA-Impfstoffe
mit ihren 95 Prozent Effektivität
unsere Erwartungen
ja alle weit übertroffen haben.
Das heißt, wir vergleichen
mit einem sehr hohen Standard.
Außerdem ist diese Impfung
vielleicht gar nicht die einzige,
die es geben wird.
Vielleicht wird's
'ne saisonale Impfung,
vielleicht gibt's im Herbst
'ne zweite Impfrunde.
Oder man muss noch mal impfen,
weil die Impfungen sich an
die Mutationen anpassen müssen.
Siehe auch Frage sechs.
Um das zu beantworten,
brauche wir ein paar Basics.
So sieht das Coronavirus
ja ungefähr aus.
Also an seiner Oberfläche sitzen
so stachelartige Proteine.
Die Spike-Proteine.
Man kann das Spike-Protein
alleine als Impfstoff nutzen.
Weil das Protein alleine natürlich
nicht COVID-19 auslösen kann.
Es aber ausreicht,
um unser Immunsystem zu aktivieren
und für das echte Virus
zu trainieren.
Wenn wir dann mal vom echten
Coronavirus infiziert werden,
denkt sich das Immunsystem:
"Ha, das kenn ich!"
Und der Angriff wird idealerweise
im Keim erstickt.
Viele Impfungen beruhen darauf,
dass man nur Teile von Viren nimmt
oder auch ganze abgetötete Viren.
Der Nachteil ist allerdings
die aufwendige Herstellung.
Beispiel: Influenza-Impfungen.
Die werden in der Regel
in Hühnereiern gezüchtet,
was ziemlich lange dauert.
Ziemlich lange dauern
können wir grade nicht gebrauchen,
weil wir schnell Impfstoffe brauchen,
in rauen Mengen.
Und hier liegt der große Vorteil
von genbasierten Impfstoffen.
Hier werden kleine Teile
der Virus DNA oder RNA
in die Zelle eingeschleust,
und zwar nur der Teil,
der den Bauplan
für das Spike-Protein trägt.
Ist der Bauplan
erst mal in unsren Zellen,
wird er abgelesen, unsre Zellen
produzieren das Spike-Protein selbst.
Diese genbasierten Impfstoffe sind
im Labor relativ leicht herzustellen.
Die eigentlich komplizierte
Herstellung des Proteins
übernehmen wir selbst.
Alle bisher zugelassenen Impfstoffe
sind genbasiert.
Es gibt die zwei mRNA-Impfstoffe
von Moderna und BioNTech/Pfizer.
Und es gibt den neuen Impfstoff
von AstraZeneca,
ein Vektorimpfstoff
und DNA-Impfstoff.
Es gibt noch zweit weitere
genbasierte Impfstoffe,
auf deren Zulassung
wir bald hoffen können,
nämlich ein mRNA-Impfstoff
von CureVac
und ein Vektorimpfstoff
von Johnson & Johnson.
Schauen wir uns das Prinzip
mRNA-Impfstoff
und Vektorimpfstoff an.
Um das Corona-Spike-Gen
einzuschleusen,
nutzt man harmlose Viren
als eine Art Transportmittel.
Diese Transportvieren nennt man
Vektoren, daher Vektorimpfstoff.
Man replizierende Vektoren nehmen,
Viren, die sich vermehren können,
aber harmlos sind,
zum Beispiel
abgeschwächte Masernviren.
So ein Konzept
hatte auch der Ebola-Impfstoff.
Oder man nimmt
nicht-replizierende Vektoren,
also Viren, die sich
nicht vermehren können,
weil die entsprechenden Gene
deaktiviert wurden.
Genau das hat AstraZeneca
mit Adenoviren gemacht.
Das Coronavirus-Gen, das den Bauplan
fürs Spike-Protein trägt,
wird in die Vektor-DNA eingebaut
und durch das Vektorvirus in die
Zelle und den Zellkern eingeschleust.
Im Zellkern passiert Folgendes.
Das Spike-Gen, also die DNA,
wird kopiert
und in mRNA umgeschrieben.
"mRNA" steht für "messenger RNA,
also "Boten-RNA".
Sie bringt den Bauplan
aus dem Zellkern
zu den Ribosomen,
den Protein-Fabriken unserer Zellen.
Dort werden gemäß der Bauanleitung
dann die Spike-Proteine hergestellt
und damit die Immunantwort gestartet.
mRNA-Impfstoffe,
wie der von BioNTech/Pfizer,
nutzen nicht DNA,
sondern direkt mRNA.
Man ist also hier
einen Schritt weiter.
Der Rest bleibt grundsätzlich gleich.
Hier braucht man keine Vektoren,
sondern nutzt solche Lipidhülle
als Transportmittel, die die mRNA
ins Zellplasma einschleusen.
Die mRNA muss nämlich nicht
in den Zellkern.
Im Zellkern findet die Transkription
von DNA zu mRNA statt.
Doch dieser Schritt
wird ja hier gespart.
Aber ist das nicht gefährlich,
wenn Virus-RNA oder -DNA
in unsere Zellen geschleust wird?
Kann dadurch unser Erbgut
verändert werden?
Fangen wir
mit den mRNA-Impfstoffen an.
Hier gibt es mehrere Gründe,
warum das nicht passieren kann.
Erstens: Die mRNA gelangt nur ins
Zellplasma und nicht in den Zellkern.
Und im Zellkern sitzt ja unsere DNA.
Das heißt, die mRNA kommt
mit unserer DNA gar nicht in Kontakt.
Zweitens: RNA kann nicht so ohne
Weiteres in DNA umgeschrieben werden.
Der Prozess läuft,
wie gesagt, andersrum.
Und drittens: Das Coronavirus
bringt ja selbst seine RNA
in unsere Zellen,
wenn wir uns damit infizieren,
und zwar seine gesamte.
Nicht nur das, es vermehrt sich
auch noch in unseren Zellen.
Das heißt, wer Angst
vor Viren-Genen hat,
müsste mehr Angst vor Corona haben
als vor der Impfung.
Nur dass diese Angst
eben unbegründet ist.
Also natürlich kann eine
Corona-Infektion gefährlich sein,
aber nicht, weil dabei
unsere Gene verändert werden.
Das passiert bei der Infektion nicht
und bei der Impfung auch nicht.
Okay, für DNA-Impfstoffe,
wie der von AstraZeneca,
gelten all die Gründe,
die ich grade genannt habe, nicht.
Denn hier schleusen wir nicht RNA,
sondern DNA in die Zelle ein.
Und zwar nicht nur ins Zytoplasma,
sondern wirklich in den Zellkern.
Kann sich fremde DNA
in unserem Zellkern
in unser Genom einbauen?
Grundsätzlich geht das schon,
nur ganz so einfach ist es nicht.
Etwa acht Prozent
des menschlichen Genoms
besteht aus Viren-DNA.
Ja.
Es gibt nämlich Viren, die ihr Erbgut
ins Wirtsgenom einschreiben können,
zum Beispiel das Retrovirus HIV.
Einfach so geht es aber nicht,
sondern nur mit Hilfsmitteln.
Und zwar gibt's ein Enzym
namens "Reverse Transkriptase",
das diesen Prozess hier
umkehren kann,
also RNA in DNA umwandelt.
Und dann noch ein zweites Enzym
namens "Integrase",
damit die DNA dann tatsächlich
auch in die Wirts-DNA integriert,
also eingebaut werden kann.
Bei den Corona-Impfungen
sind diese notwendigen Enzyme
natürlich nicht dabei.
Das ist das Erste.
Zweitens: Die Viren,
die AstraZeneca oder Johnson &
Johnson als Vektoren benutzt,
sind Adenoviren.
Adenoviren kennen wir auch von
unseren harmlosen Erkältungsviren,
da sind auch Adenoviren mit dabei.
Und Adenoviren zählen
zu den nicht integrierenden Viren.
Sie schleusen sich zwar
in den Zellkern ein,
liegen da aber episomal vor,
das heißt, neben unserer DNA.
Außerdem führt
das Ablesen der Spike-DNA
ja zur Produktion
von den Spike-Proteinen,
die ja dann vom Immunsystem
attackiert werden.
Wobei die Zellen,
die die Virusproteine herstellen,
dann sowieso getötet werden.
Also, die Befürchtung,
dass genbasierte Impfstoffe
durch Genomveränderungen
Nebenwirkungen auslösen könnten,
sind unbegründet.
Aber schauen wir uns die Sorge
über Nebenwirkungen allgemeiner an.
Erst mal kurz
zu den häufigen Nebenwirkungen
wie leichte Schmerzen an der
Einstichstelle oder Abgeschlagenheit,
diese Symptome sind Teil der normalen
Impfreaktion, man sagt auch:
Und ein Zeichen dafür, dass unser
Immunsystem seinen Job macht.
Schwerere Nebenwirkungen
sind bei Impfungen selten.
Denn die Sicherheitsansprüche
an eine Impfung
sind einfach extrem hoch.
Also bei einem Krebsmedikament
gegen einen tödlichen Krebs
kann man auch schwerere
Nebenwirkungen in Kauf nehmen.
Bei einer Impfung, die gesunden
Menschen verabreicht wird, nicht.
Aber:
Bei BioNTech/Pfizer
hatte man in Phase Drei,
also in der letzten klinischen Phase
vor der Zulassung,
über 40.000 Probanden.
Was sehr viel ist.
Normalerweise sind es
eher Tausende und nicht Zehntausende.
Doch wenn eine Nebenwirkung nur
in einem von 10.000 Fällen auftritt,
würde man sie auch
bei dieser Probandengröße
nicht als statistisch signifikant
wahrnehmen.
Zumal ja auch nur die Hälfte
der Gruppe geimpft wird,
die restlichen 20.000
sind ja in der Placebogruppe.
Deswegen gibt es bei Impfstoffen,
genau wie bei Medikamenten,
eine Phase Vier,
eine sorgfältige Beobachtung
nach der Zulassung.
Das Infektionsschutzgesetz
schreibt vor,
dass jede Nebenwirkung,
die nach einer Impfung auftritt,
dem Gesundheitsamt
gemeldet werden muss.
Das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
sammelt dann alles.
Übrigens kann es auch jede*r selbst
melden, etwa über dieses Formular.
Die Schwierigkeit bei Phase Vier ist,
dass wir dann
keine Kontrollgruppe mehr haben.
Also, wir haben natürlich
viele Nicht-Geimpfte,
aber das bringt ja nichts.
Wir bräuchten
nach wie vor eine Gruppe,
der wir eine Placebo-Spritze geben.
Da wir das nicht mehr haben,
sind Nebenwirkungen,
vor allem, wenn sie
vereinzelt und selten auftreten,
gar nicht so einfach der Impfung
zuzuschreiben oder auch nicht.
Es geht bei Phase Vier darum
aufmerksam zu sein, zu beobachten und
Verdachtsfälle ausfindig zu machen,
die man dann näher untersucht.
Okay, aber warum macht man dann
nicht noch eine klinische Studie?
Eine größere
mit Hunderttausenden Probanden
und mit gescheiter Kontrollgruppe?
Man könnte das machen,
das würde den Impfstoff
aber noch zurückhalten.
In der statistischen Risikoabwägung
kommt man an einen Punkt,
wo man ganz klar
mehr Schaden anrichtet,
wenn man einen Impfstoff zurückhält,
der schon an Zehntausenden getestet
sich als sicher erwiesen hat,
als wenn man den noch weiter testet,
nur um das bereits geringe Risiko
noch ein Stückchen zu verringern.
Das Risiko steht ohnehin schon
in keinem Verhältnis
zu den Risiken von COVID-19.
Was, wenn viel später
Nebenwirkungen auftreten,
die sich in den ersten Tagen,
Wochen, Monaten nach der Impfung
noch nicht zeigen?
Oft wird in diesem Zusammenhang
auf die Impfung
gegen Schweinegrippe verwiesen.
Bei der ein Impfstoff
namens "Pandemrix"
Narkolepsie ausgelöst hat.
Narkolepsie ist
eine relativ seltene Krankheit,
die unter anderem
mit Kataplexie einhergeht.
Kataplexie ist ein plötzliches
Erschlaffen der Muskeln,
sodass sich die Betroffenen
eine Zeit lang nicht bewegen können,
ähnlich wie eine Ohnmacht
bei vollem Bewusstsein.
Der Pandemrix-Narkolepsie-Fall
ist unglaublich spannend.
Also wirklich wie ein Science-Krimi
und auch noch ziemlich relevant
für die Corona-Impfungen.
Allerdings ist das Ganze
sehr komplex.
Damit dieses Video
nicht gesprengt wird,
hat Lars aus unserem maiLab-Team
quasi extra für euch
einen Blogartikel dazu geschrieben,
in dem alles im Detail erklärt wird.
Kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen,
denn danach wisst ihr Bescheid.
Da Narkolepsie
eine chronische Krankheit ist,
ist der Pandemrix-Fall
ein seltenes Fallbeispiel dafür,
dass eine Impfung
nachhaltige Schäden,
also Langzeitschäden, verursacht hat.
Aber die Symptome für Narkolepsie,
die traten meist nach wenigen Wochen
bis Monaten nach der Impfung auf.
Und so ist auch die Erfahrung
mit anderen Impfungen.
Und wohlgemerkt laufen die klinischen
Studien der mRNA-Impfstoffe
schon seit Sommer 2020,
und die laufen ja immer noch.
Und zumindest bis jetzt
haben sich noch keine
verspäteten Nebenwirkungen gezeigt.
Auch hier könnte man natürlich
die Studien länger laufen lassen.
Aber auch hier
müsste man dann verantworten,
den Impfstoff
so lange zurückzuhalten.
Das Risiko, dass völlig unerwartet
verspätete Nebenwirkungen auftreten,
die man bis jetzt
nicht auf dem Schirm hat,
ist so klein,
dass es in keinem Verhältnis steht
zu den Risiken von COVID-19.
Auch hier gilt,
wer jetzt eine Impfung ablehnt
und lieber noch wartet,
ist risikofreudiger als jemand,
der ein Impfangebot annimmt.
Viren vermehren sich ja,
indem sie in Wirtszellen
ganz viele Kopien von sich machen.
Und bei diesen Kopiervorgängen
passieren immer wieder
kleine Fehlerchen.
Also kleine Mutationen
im Erbgut des Virus.
Die meisten dieser Mutationen
haben keine weitere Bedeutung,
aber es kann
immer mal wieder passieren,
dass rein zufällig
eine Mutation dabei ist,
die irgendeinen Vorteil gegenüber
dem Wildtyp, also dem Original, hat.
Also, dass die Mutante
zum Beispiel ansteckender ist.
Und wenn so ein Vorteil besteht,
kann sich diese Mutante
gegenüber dem Wildtyp durchsetzen.
Evolution.
Mutationen müssen
nicht zwingend schlecht sein.
Also evolutionstechnisch
ist es für das Virus sogar gut,
weniger schädlich zu werden,
dafür aber ansteckender.
Also das Beste,
was einem Virus passieren kann, ist,
dass es sehr ansteckend ist,
aber dass der Wirt so fit ist,
dass er rumläuft
und viele andere Leute ansteckt,
damit es sich
umso mehr verbreiten kann.
Momentan haben wir ja den Salat,
dass wir Mutanten haben,
die nicht weniger schädlich sind,
aber ansteckender.
Tricky wird's, wenn sich
durch Mutation das Spike-Protein
so stark verändert, dass unser
Immunsystem es nicht mehr erkennt.
Dann spricht man von "Immune Escape".
Also, das Virus
kann der Immunantwort entgehen.
Aber heißt das ...
dass alles wieder von vorne losgeht?
Jein. Wir werden jetzt
keine zweite Pandemie haben.
Also 2020 wird jetzt nicht
wieder von vorne losgehen.
Denn man kann nicht davon ausgehen,
dass sich das Virus so krass mutiert,
dass es plötzlich
ein ganz anderes Virus ist,
mit dem unsere Immunsystem
gar nichts mehr anfangen kann.
Also, wer geimpft ist oder die
Krankheit schon mal durchgemacht hat,
kann sich dann
mit irgendeiner neuen Mutante
vielleicht noch mal anstecken,
darf dann aber trotzdem
mit einem milderen Verlauf rechnen.
Weil man dann eine gewisse
Grund- oder Kreuzimmunität hat.
Das Kritische ist aber,
dass wir jetzt schon,
bevor wir ausreichend geimpft sind,
die ansteckenderen Mutanten
schon im Umlauf haben.
Das heißt, dass wir jetzt noch sehr
stark auf unsere anderen Maßnahmen,
auf unsere Schutz- und
Hygienemaßnahmen, angewiesen sind.
Wenn die nicht richtig greifen,
dann laufen wir viel leichter in neue
Ausbrüche, Wellen und Lockdowns rein.
Also, so was kann tatsächlich
immer wieder passieren.
Aber zur Impfeffektivität,
also zumindest
bei der britischen Variante B.1.1.7,
die ja bei uns
noch am stärksten in Umlauf ist,
scheint es gut auszusehen.
Da scheinen bisher alle Impfstoffe
trotzdem zu wirken.
Über andere Mutanten,
wie die südafrikanische Variante,
gibt's derzeit
beunruhigende Medienberichte.
Wir wissen noch nicht genau,
wie da die Impfstoffwirksamkeit ist.
Es ist natürlich
nicht ausgeschlossen,
dass das Coronavirus
noch weiter mutiert,
bis die Impfungen
vielleicht nicht mehr greifen.
Dann ...
müssten die Impfstoffe
tatsächlich angepasst werden.
Hier ist dann wieder der große
Vorteil der genbasierten Impfstoffe,
weil die könnte man deutlich
schneller und einfacher
anpassen und neu herstellen
als Impfstoffe,
die erst gezüchtet werden müssen.
Sollten Geimpfte wieder
in Restaurants, auf Konzerte
oder in Klubs gehen können?
Das ist natürlich eine rechtliche
und gesellschaftliche Frage,
aber ihr liegt eine wesentliche
wissenschaftliche Frage zugrunde:
Die Frage nach
der sterilisierenden Immunität.
Also können Geimpfte
andere noch weiter anstecken?
Bisher wissen wir eigentlich nur:
Das heißt, Geimpfte können
andere immer noch anstecken, aber:
Wir wissen nur nicht, wie viel.
Und so lange wir
das noch nicht wissen,
also diese Frage muss uns
die Wissenschaft beantworten,
können wir auch diese rechtliche
und gesellschaftliche Frage
gar nicht sinnvoll abwägen.
Das hier nur so als keiner Reminder.
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare,
was ihr dazu denkt.
Falls ihr noch 'ne wissenschaftliche
Frage habt zu den Impfungen,
die wir nicht beantwortet haben,
könnt ihr sie stellen unter:
#keksfrage.
Dann werden Jens, Lars und ich
in den nächsten Tagen
immer mal wieder
nach diesem Hashtag gucken
und versuchen,
möglichst viel zu beantworten.
Eine Frage haben wir
extra ausgelassen:
Können Impfungen unfruchtbar machen?
Denn diese Frage hat der liebe
Martin Moder so gut beantwortet,
dass wir dem nichts mehr
hinzuzufügen hatten.
Stattdessen verlinken wir
auf sein Video
zusammen mit einer
ganz fetten Keksempfehlung,
also eine Abo-Empfehlung
für den ganzen Kanal.
Wir sehen uns bald.
Und bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!